también hay un límite a lo que el
los acuerdos comerciales pueden hacer por
favor de que sean mujeres de la
pequeñas empresas comerciales
pueblos indígenas para promover una
desarrollo sostenible y eso significa
que realmente tenemos que retroceder
a menudo en acuerdos multilaterales
más amplios o incluso permitir acuerdos
también gran latitud
a las políticas económicas de cada
en cada país para poder abordar sus
apuestas en los acuerdos comerciales
no tenía ninguna obstrucción política
en cada país en esta área
entonces hay un Yo diría que hay un
el complejísimo mosaico de acordes
el comercio es sólo una parte de
es parte del problema cuando hay
problema
pero también parte de la solución
solamente